The URL that we built looks good, and the JSON string from the server,
also looks good, however, it still is one long string.
Let's look at it more carefully to see what data, we should extract from it.
In order to make sense of the string that comes back from the server.
We can put it through a JSON formatter or a JSON prettifier.
If you Google for
those terms, you'll be able to find a helpful tool, such as this one.
Here we pasted the result of the web query.
Then it formatted the output for us, showing us the hierarchy of these element.
Now based on the wire frames that you saw for the sunshine app,
can you tell us which of these leaf nodes we care about extracting?
Even though we will have to traverse through parent nodes, for the purposes of
the quiz on the next screen, we're just looking at the leaf nodes.
Make your selection below on which attributes we'll need to
display the list of forecasts.